well meanwhile hundreds of websites
including major news organizations and
the british government
have now started to work again after
going offline for about an hour
an outage at a cloud services company is
thought to have been to blame
the sites affected include the new york
times cnn the guardian and bloomberg
news
the san francisco-based company fastly
which hosts the websites
says it's now fixed the problem well
let's now speak to jody westby she is
the chief executive of global cyber risk
she joins us now
from washington dc jody how does
something like this happen
well this the good news is this was not
a cyber attack as far as we know
this was a configuration problem it was
a configuration service problem
and they they fixed that and were back
up
so it was a glitch in their system but
it shows how interconnected
we all are and how one problem
even in one small place can ripple
through
and spread across the globe and impact
you know millions of of internet users
well jody so many of the biggest
websites in the world are
by my understanding dependent on just a
few of these cloud servicing companies
that all sounds rather fragile can you
explain how that all works
think of it as a sandwich so you have
the
main service provider like google or new
york times or
guardian and then you have
the meat on the sandwich and on top you
have the customer
so fastly is like the meat in a sandwich
it is there to take the content and
deliver it very fast to the consumer
to the user up above and
vastly was impacted so the meat and the
sandwich like went away
and then the customer couldn't connect
and
so it was a service that is a very
important service in delivering content
around the world
and it was disrupted again because of
this configuration setting
and um and it impacted all these people
because it was such a critical layer
in the service delivery well as we were
saying earlier one of the sites that
went down was the british government's
site for instance are there security
concerns here i know you were saying it
wasn't an
attack but does this lay it open to to
perhaps
other attacks like this
um well i don't again as far as we know
this wasn't an
attack um so things can happen in
computer systems they're complicated and
there's
a lot of servers and routers and
switches and equipment
and networks all connecting and when
there
is a problem that has a ripple effect
then it
again it just shows how globally
connected we are
and how one small thing can have a large
impact
so sure i mean there's all kinds of
configuration setting issues or problems
this
obviously doesn't happen every day but
it is possible it could happen again and
it could be a different type of problem
jody doesn't outage like this have any
monetary or financial implications
oh yes so if you're a company that makes
money by the minute
so amazon for example ebay any of the
online services that are selling
uh goods or services um all of those
companies
lose money this is a business
interruption for them every
second that they're down and so many
companies
for example if you're processing credit
cards often those will get stored
in a in the server when you come back up
then they can process them
not thousands but usually they could
handle a few hundred
and so that isn't really a business
interruption but when you
can't make money and you lose those
minutes they're gone
so so it can have enormous business
interruption
losses even though this was a relatively
short period of an avenue
and a reminder as you say how connected
we are and how fragile all of this is
jody westby there the chief executive of
global cyber risk
great to get your expertise with us here
on al jazeera thanks for joining us jody